Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
挑战中还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Thank you for being part of my world. And if you're listening to this live, I hope you're having a good summer so far. This morning, I was planning on recording a podcast episode before I had to do a guest podcast episode that I was doing for somebody else on grief. And it was on my to-do list, along with cleaning up my email inbox, which had been a little bit unchecked for about three or four days because things had just got a bit busy. But unfortunately the email inbox took longer than expected as is often the case and so yeah the podcast episode didn't get done and I just looked at it on my to-do list just as I was getting ready to finish for the day
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你正在收听直播，希望你到目前为止度过了一个愉快的夏天。今天早上，我原本计划录制一期播客，之后还要为别人录制一期关于悲伤的嘉宾播客。这在我的待办事项清单上，还有清理我的电子邮箱，因为忙碌，我已经有三四天没管它了。但不幸的是，清理邮箱花的时间比预期的要长，这是常有的事，所以播客没录成。当我准备结束一天的工作时，看着待办清单上的这一项，
and I thought oh it's too late now because the children are already here I've already picked them up from school and then I thought you know what they're both not in the room that I'm in they're happily playing together this is kind of how it's going to be over the summer because I speak to you before the schools have broken up at the moment and I thought well I'm just going to go for it. You know it would be a shame not to tick this off my to-do list and I can stand in my own way with excuses about why I can't do things or I can just get on and do it. So that is what I'm doing and it might be that this is timely for you. So that is what I'm doing. And it might be that this is timely for you. So today's episode is something that will likely happen to all of us at some point in our career. It may even happen at numerous times, numerous points in our career, because it's a really normal part of life. But I think when we work in the profession
我心想，太晚了，孩子们已经放学回家了。然后我又想，他们现在不在我这个房间，正开心地玩在一起。暑假期间大概就是这样，因为我在学校放假前录制这期节目。我想，好吧，我还是坚持录完吧。如果因为各种借口而不去完成待办事项，那太可惜了，我可以直接去做。这就是我正在做的，也许这对你来说正合时宜。所以，今天的话题是我们职业生涯中迟早会遇到的情况。它甚至可能在职业生涯的多个阶段发生，因为这是生活中非常正常的一部分。但我认为，当我们从事这个职业时，
that we do, it can be easy to get knocked and bumped along the way by people. And what we're talking about today is when things go wrong and when you might feel like quitting and running away and joining the circus and doing something that is so very different to working in the psychology field. And that does happen. When I was an assistant psychologist, somebody jacked it all in and became a personal trainer. They just decided enough of this shenanigans when I was at St Andrews somebody um quit their forensic qualification route I've decided it was no longer for them and went off surfing instead um and the last I heard was having a very lovely life indeed so you, it doesn't say anything about you.
很容易在前进的道路上受到挫折。我们今天要讨论的是当事情出错，当你想要放弃、逃跑、去马戏团工作，或者做一些与心理学领域完全不同的事情时该怎么办。这种情况确实会发生。当我还是助理心理学家时，有人放弃了一切去当私人教练。当我还在圣安德鲁斯大学时，有人退出了法医资格认证，决定那不再适合他们，转而去冲浪了。我最后一次听说他们时，他们过着非常美好的生活。所以，这并不代表你有什么问题。
If you decide it's not for you, that's okay. But what I'm talking to and who I'm talking to and the eventualities that I'm talking to in this episode are when things happen that make you feel really ouchy. So we're not talking necessarily about, you know, just an underlying sense that this isn't the career for you. Actually, I've changed my mind. We're talking about something that's happened that's led a different part of yourself to feel really hurt, really confused and like running away. So let me give you some examples of where this type of scenario might crop up for you. So it might be that you are in sort of a relevant experience role and maybe something has happened perhaps on one of the wards or one of the units that you work in maybe there's been an incident and it's making you feel like
如果你决定这不适合你，那也没关系。但我在这期节目中要讨论的是那些让你感到非常痛苦的情况。我们不一定是在讨论你内心深处觉得这不适合你，或者你改变了主意。我们讨论的是发生了某些事情，让你感到非常受伤、困惑，甚至想要逃跑。让我举几个例子，看看这种情况可能会在什么时候出现。比如，你可能正在从事一份相关经验的工作，也许在病房或单位里发生了一些事情，也许是一起事故，让你觉得
this isn't going to work out for you or maybe you know there's an investigation into the role all staff members played in whatever the incident might be. And that can lead to lots of our human brains really mulling things over and really trying to make sense of what has happened. And, you know, we might have all sorts of complicated human emotions coming up as well. We might have shame and guilt embarrassment remorse regret and yeah it can feel really ouchy you know and there's one school of thought that shame was always supposed to feel ouchy but that it was supposed to be so uncomfortable that it kept us
这行不通了，或者也许正在对所有员工在事故中的角色进行调查。这会导致我们的大脑不断反思，试图弄清楚发生了什么。而且，我们可能会产生各种复杂的人类情绪，比如羞耻、内疚、尴尬、懊悔和遗憾。这确实会让人感到痛苦。有一种观点认为，羞耻感本就应该是痛苦的，它应该足够令人不适，从而阻止我们
from doing things that might lead us to experience that shame. So I'm not saying that you should feel ashamed for whatever it is that's going on. I'm just making sense of any shame that you do feel. And please know you can only experience that because of your human brain as well. And you definitely didn't ask to be human I certainly didn't we're just making our best way through this world with this incredibly tricky brain that we've got. So another example where this might crop up for you is perhaps within a supervisory relationship within your role perhaps there's just a bit of a mismatch. There might be that you're getting feedback about your performance with clients or your academic writing style or the way that you speak to the supervisor or your juniors or your seniors. And please know that it might not necessarily be you that the problem is with you
去做那些可能导致羞耻的事情。所以我并不是说你应该为正在发生的事情感到羞耻。我只是在解读你所感受到的任何羞耻感。请记住，你之所以能感受到这些，是因为你拥有人类的大脑。你绝对没有要求成为人类，我当然也没有。我们只是带着这颗极其复杂的大脑，尽力在这个世界上前行。另一个例子是，这种情况可能出现在你的督导关系中，也许只是有点不匹配。你可能会收到关于你与客户表现、学术写作风格，或者你与督导、下属或上司沟通方式的反馈。请记住，问题不一定出在你身上。
know we are like really intricate jigsaw puzzles aren't we and we can't expect all of the pieces to align all of the time you know sometimes there's going to be bits that don't want to fit, bits that don't want to lie flat. And sometimes we're going to find it more difficult to get things to lie flat with some people compared to, you know, to other people where things just feel more effortless. And as you reflect upon your life, you will be able to think about people that you could happily spend hours in the company of but not talking to you will be able to think about people that you could happily spend hours talking to in a really engaged switched on way that feels really academically and you know just professionally exciting there will be maybe maybe not even academically you know
我们就像复杂的拼图，不能指望所有的碎片时刻都能完美契合。有时会有一些碎片不想拼在一起，或者不想平整地放置。有时我们会发现，与某些人相比，与另一些人相处时，事情更难平稳进行，而与另一些人相处时，一切感觉更自然。当你反思自己的生活时，你会想到那些你可以愉快地共度时光的人，即使不说话；你也会想到那些你可以愉快地交谈、感到非常投入、在学术和专业上都感到兴奋的人。
maybe this is just someone in your personal life that you could talk to for hours but in a way that feels really good um you feel really enlivened to be around them maybe there's other people that you feel like you want to talk more to kind of anxiety you know you feel like these silences are uncomfortable and maybe there's just people who fit in between these parts. You know, maybe there's people that you just also don't want to spend any time at all with. You know, perhaps you can imagine really uncomfortable meetings that you've had in the past where staff members just aren't getting on. They're not liking each other. You know, I was watching The Last Dance yesterday, which is not at all about dancing. It's on Netflix and it is about Michael Jordan in the Chicago Bulls.
也许这只是你个人生活中可以交谈数小时的人，那种感觉非常好，你感到与他们在一起充满活力。也许还有其他人，你觉得想多说点话，但感到焦虑，觉得沉默很尴尬。也许还有一些人介于两者之间。也许还有一些人你根本不想花任何时间在一起。你可以想象过去那些不舒服的会议，员工们相处不融洽，互相不喜欢。我昨天在看《最后之舞》（The Last Dance），那根本不是关于跳舞的，是在Netflix上关于迈克尔·乔丹和芝加哥公牛队的纪录片。
And they were talking about one of the team who had just, it was episode two, if you want to know specifically which one I'm talking about. There was a member of the team who just after a while was so kind of cross with his position that he started kind of being quite disparaging about one of the managers and it made it quite uncomfortable for everybody really you know he'd be shouting things on tour buses and you know just it just all got really complicated and we can probably you know picture relationships like that that might have happened in staff teams that you're working with as well hopefully you're
他们谈到了其中一名队员，那是第二集，如果你想知道具体是哪一集的话。队里有一名成员，过了一段时间后，对自己的位置非常不满，开始贬低其中一位经理，这让所有人都感到非常不舒服。他会在巡回巴士上大喊大叫，事情变得非常复杂。我们大概能想象在你的工作团队中也可能发生过类似的职场关系。希望你
not the one shouting things at your at your staff teams but you know we can't expect everybody to get along all of the time and this reminds me of some other stuff um you know with Carl Mahe in episode 31 we're talking about leadership and change and cultural kind of temperatures of organizations and if you like this way of thinking you might find it helpful to listen to that episode as well so that's Carl Mahe episode 31 but you know if you find yourself being the one who feels like you're being singled out or criticised for some reason, that can feel really, really conflicting. That can feel really, really complicated. And another example might be that if you are perhaps in a university environment and you're getting feedback about yourself, perhaps your essays aren't, you know, they're not seeming to garner the results that you feel they ought to be.
不是那个对团队大喊大叫的人。但我们不能指望每个人都能一直和睦相处。这让我想起了其他一些事情，比如在第31集中，我和Carl Mahe讨论了领导力、变革以及组织的文化氛围。如果你喜欢这种思维方式，你可能会觉得听那一集也很有帮助。那是第31集。但如果你发现自己因为某种原因被孤立或批评，那会感到非常矛盾和复杂。另一个例子是，如果你在大学环境中，收到关于你自己的反馈，也许你的论文似乎没有取得你认为应该取得的结果。
Or when you compare the feedback you're getting to that of your fellow cohort, it just doesn't feel like you're being treated that fairly or you's be you're being you know given different feedback to other people um and it might be that because you've got um different skills and talents it might be that you know when we spoke to dr deborah kingston for episode 30 she recognized that she was dyslexic um well she didn't it, one of her tutors did. So it might be that maybe writing is something that you find more challenging, and that you could do with some extra support in that. And so I guess that's one of our first pieces of advice here. It would be to think about whether you've got any formal sources of support available to you to help you get a different opinion on where you're at
或者当你将收到的反馈与同学进行比较时，感觉自己没有受到公平对待，或者你收到的反馈与其他人不同。这可能是因为你有不同的技能和天赋。当我们为第30集采访Deborah Kingston博士时，她意识到自己有阅读障碍，其实是她的导师发现的。所以，写作可能对你来说更具挑战性，你可能需要额外的支持。我想这是我们的第一个建议：考虑一下你是否有任何正式的支持渠道，可以帮助你获得关于你目前处境的不同意见。
right now. So it might be that you've got a centre for academic writing, perhaps linked to the university that you are doing your studying with. It might be that you have got a personal tutor, perhaps as part of whatever course you're studying, that you can access to have some advice and discussion with about how you're feeling. At this point, let's take a short break. And I will be back along with some more pieces of advice that might be useful if this is happening to you or indeed to someone that you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book.
现在，也许你所在的大学有学术写作中心。也许你所在的课程有个人导师，你可以找他们咨询并讨论你的感受。现在，让我们休息一下。稍后我会回来，提供更多建议，如果这种情况发生在你身上，或者发生在你认识的合格专业人士身上，这些建议可能会有用。来看看吧，就在这本书里。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective book is really informative and helpful in preparation for clinical training. It gives some good food for thought and lots to reflect on. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Hi, welcome back. So we've been thinking in the first half about the different types of situations that you might encounter that might make you feel a little bit wobbly and like quitting a role or quitting, you know, an entire career. But yeah, so we've covered a couple of examples about what you might do in an academic setting. Within occupational settings, it might be that there's another member of your team that you could talk through how you're feeling sort of more
这是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。这本书在临床培训准备方面非常有信息量和帮助。它提供了一些很好的思考点，有很多值得反思的内容。就在这本书里。这是《临床心理学家集体》。你好，欢迎回来。在前半部分，我们思考了你可能会遇到的不同类型的情况，这些情况可能会让你感到动摇，想要辞职或放弃整个职业生涯。我们讨论了一些你在学术环境中可能会遇到的例子。在职业环境中，也许你可以与团队中的另一位成员讨论你的感受，
informally or more on the record as well you know perhaps there's a team manager who you have a good relationship with that you could talk about these things with of course you could speak to your supervisor yourself and have that on the table and have a discussion about what might be going on and this point you might find it helpful if you haven't done so already to go and grab your free supervision shaping tool which you can do by checking out the link in the show notes and but I do believe goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision I'm fairly sure that's right but yeah that way you can get um the supervision shaping tool straight into your inbox um and that will then help set up any future supervisory relationships in a way that helps you
无论是更非正式地还是正式地。也许有一位你关系很好的团队经理，你可以和他们讨论这些事情。当然，你可以直接与你的督导沟通，把问题摆在桌面上讨论。此时，如果你还没有这样做，你可能会发现获取免费的“督导塑造工具”（supervision shaping tool）很有帮助，你可以查看节目说明中的链接。我相信是goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/supervision，我相当确定是这个地址。通过这种方式，你可以直接将督导塑造工具发送到你的收件箱，这将有助于以一种帮助你的方式建立未来的督导关系，
know how you're going to problem solve if there are problems in future um but if you haven't done that already you could still think about bringing that to supervision to just help you examine the temperature of the water and how to have things be different. If you feel like it's not really the time for that, then of course, if you are employed, you could think about discussing your concerns with HR. And if you can't get a good fit with the current supervisor, you could, in fact, consider whether you might have a different supervisor within that role. And it might be that that's perhaps not in your immediate service and that you access supervision somewhere else. But it's really difficult if you do have such a breakdown of relationship um and it's understandable if you feel like you want to look around for jobs that might feel like they're a better fit for you not because you're not good
让你知道如果未来出现问题该如何解决。但如果你还没有这样做，你仍然可以考虑在督导中提出这个问题，以帮助你审视水温，并思考如何改变现状。如果你觉得现在不是时候，那么如果你是受雇的，你可以考虑与人力资源部门讨论你的担忧。如果你无法与当前的督导达成良好的契合，你实际上可以考虑在那个职位中是否可以换一位督导。也许那不在你直接的服务范围内，你可以在其他地方获得督导。但如果关系破裂，确实非常困难，如果你想寻找更适合你的工作，这是可以理解的，并不是因为你不够好，
for that job sometimes things just don't align um and so yeah sometimes people contact me and they're really demoralized by the experience that they're having at any particular job and I have to say that on balance it sounds like it's not them that's the problem and actually in a different environment somebody might be really celebrating their success and really pleased with you know their performance and then they go on to get a different job and they contact me and they're like oh my god this is so different you were right you know it wasn't me it was just that there was a a bad fit you know a bad culture fit as um as cull would say it was just you know it wasn't working out
而是因为有时事情就是无法协调。有时人们联系我，对他们在某份工作中的经历感到非常沮丧。我不得不说，总的来说，听起来问题不在他们身上。实际上，在不同的环境中，有人可能会非常赞赏他们的成功，并对他们的表现感到非常满意。然后他们去了一份新工作，联系我说：“天哪，这太不一样了，你是对的，不是我的问题，只是之前的文化不匹配。”正如Carl所说，只是因为某种原因，
for whatever reason but they've been able to move past that perhaps a bit of therapy to work out what the lasting legacy has been from that and if there's been one but to be able to take themselves and their development and their advancing skills forward and it can be useful to think about job roles as you know what can I gain from this role what can I give to this role how can I try on these shoes whilst I'm in this role and then when I leave what might I like to keep what might I like to take with me and there might be some things that you're really pretty pleased to leave behind and I found that in training you know during my placements was that for some stuff I really liked it. I'm definitely going to keep that. I love that. And for other stuff, I'm like, no, not keen to ever do that again.
它不适合。但他们已经能够超越这一点，也许通过一些治疗来解决那段经历留下的持久影响（如果有的话），并能够带着他们的发展和进步的技能继续前进。把工作角色看作是“我能从这个角色中获得什么？我能为这个角色贡献什么？当我在这个角色中时，我如何尝试这些鞋子？当我离开时，我想保留什么？我想带走什么？”这会很有用。有些事情你可能很高兴能抛在脑后。我在培训期间的实习中发现，有些东西我真的很喜欢，我肯定会保留，我喜欢它。而对于其他东西，我会想，不，我再也不想做了。
And, you know, that's OK. And I think sometimes we can do the same with with our roles as we're heading towards becoming a trainee as well. So it can feel, you know, I think I'm sort of reflecting on what it's like when you are a young person in a school, or when you've got children, or when you work with children, perhaps in CAMHS services, is that it can feel like this time period in our lives and their lives is going to last forever but what we know is things quickly change um you know in cam services you know young people would come in and see me and it would all feel like everything was the end of the world and then a week later you know a teacher's gone on long-term sick or um you know a new person's joined the school or someone hasn't been at school
这没关系。我认为有时我们在走向成为实习生的过程中，也可以对我们的角色做同样的事情。我想我在反思当你在学校里是一个年轻人，或者当你有了孩子，或者当你与孩子一起工作（例如在CAMHS服务中）时，那种感觉就像我们生活中的这段时期和他们的生活将永远持续下去。但我们知道事情变化很快。在CAMHS服务中，年轻人会来见我，感觉一切都是世界末日，但一周后，也许老师请了长期病假，或者有新人加入了学校，或者有人没去学校，
and so the bullying hasn't been around and things are very different even a week later and I think we can absolutely keep changing and keep rolling with the changes that our life brings us but but to think about perhaps some of the difficult areas as being states rather than traits. But if you recognise that whatever you're going through right now is impacting on you in a longer term way, it's making you feel depressed or anxious, fearful, perhaps even traumatised, you know, then that's starting to become a trait, you know, and that's not okay. And so we need to think about whether you might reach out for occupational health at that point to help think about how to protect you and to help you to feel better and differently in future. So that is also an option. But, you know,
所以欺凌现象消失了，一周后情况就大不相同了。我认为我们绝对可以不断改变，并随着生活带来的变化而调整。但要考虑将一些困难领域视为“状态”而不是“特质”。如果你意识到你现在所经历的一切正在长期影响你，让你感到抑郁、焦虑、恐惧，甚至创伤，那么这开始变成一种“特质”，这就不好了。因此，我们需要考虑你是否可以在那时寻求职业健康部门的帮助，以保护自己，并帮助你在未来感觉更好、有所不同。这也是一个选择。但是，
I think it's just really tricky. You know, we can have, we can get so many knocks and bumps and scrapes along the way. And these can come in the form of feedback from clients as well. You know, some clients aren't going to like you. No matter how good you are, there will be some clients who just don't get you or don't like you, or you've just got a bit of a mismatch no matter what you do they don't seem to get it there was one client who complained about me when I was working in an adult service and you know when we looked into it it didn't seem like the complaint was that justified I think it was just a mismatch you know know. But even then, it feels horrid when you get a complaint coming about you. It can make you feel like, oh, what's the point? Oh, I'm going to
我认为这真的很棘手。我们一路上会遇到很多挫折、磕碰和擦伤。这些也可能来自客户的反馈。有些客户就是不会喜欢你。无论你有多优秀，总会有一些客户就是不理解你，或者不喜欢你，或者无论你做什么，你们就是不匹配。他们似乎就是不明白。我还在成人服务部门工作时，有一位客户投诉了我。当我们调查时，投诉似乎并不合理，我认为这只是不匹配。但即便如此，当你收到关于你的投诉时，感觉还是很糟糕。它会让你觉得，哦，有什么意义？哦，我要
quit, you know. I'm just going to comfort you. I'm going to just look after myself and eat ice cream for the rest of my life. I'm rubbish. I'm ridiculous. Even if we didn't particularly rate the opinion of the person giving the feedback it can still feel like it knocks you when you do get that feedback because you know when we're setting out to help people in this profession you know we're certainly you're not getting paid that much and so you know sometimes the feeling we get from the work we do is the stuff that makes the difference. And so if we're just getting not that good money and like negative feedback all the time, you can really be bogged down by it, you know, and that can really a hard time, reach out to somebody you care about or someone who is supportive. This might be a friend in psychology. It might be a friend out of psychology.
辞职了。我要去安慰自己，我要照顾好自己，余生都吃冰淇淋。我很烂，我很可笑。即使我们并不特别看重给出反馈的人的意见，当你收到那样的反馈时，它仍然会让你感到受挫。因为当你在这个职业中致力于帮助他人时，你赚的钱并不多，所以有时我们从工作中获得的感受才是最重要的。如果我们赚的钱不多，而且一直收到负面反馈，你真的会被它拖累。如果你度过了一段艰难的时光，请联系你关心的人或支持你的人。这可能是心理学领域的朋友，也可能是领域外的朋友。
It might be a partner, might be a parent, might be an auntie, might even be me. You know, someone that you trust. Let me know what's going on for you. Please know you're not alone. Please know that whatever you're feeling and experiencing, it's only possible because of this unique, tricky human brain of ours. And yeah, you're lovely. You're really striving for this career, you know, and you're not doing this because you think it's going to get you, you know, golden shoes and things. You're doing this because you genuinely care about easing the stress in other
可能是伴侣、父母、阿姨，甚至可能是我。找一个你信任的人。告诉我你发生了什么。请知道你并不孤单。请知道无论你感受到什么、经历什么，这都只是因为我们这颗独特而复杂的人类大脑。你很可爱，你真的在为这个职业而努力。你做这些不是因为你认为这会给你带来金鞋子之类的东西。你做这些是因为你真心关心减轻他人的压力，
people's lives and helping people understand themselves and the world better and have a different experience. You know, this isn't like a narcissistic career. You're doing this because you genuinely care about other people and that makes you very special. But it also means that you might get bumped and scraped along the way. We don't want hardened professionals. We want human ones. And so please know that it's OK to be human, but make sure you're being well supported. And with that in mind, if you would like to register for your interest for the Aspiring Psychologist membership,
帮助人们更好地了解自己和世界，并获得不同的体验。这不是一种自恋的职业。你做这些是因为你真心关心他人，这让你非常特别。但也意味着你一路上可能会遇到磕碰和擦伤。我们不需要冷酷的专业人士，我们需要有血有肉的人。所以请知道，做人是可以的，但要确保你得到了很好的支持。考虑到这一点，如果你想注册加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），
there are spaces becoming available again i believe it's friday the 2nd of september at 8 a.m but you need to be on the list and you'll only be able to come on board if you are on the list so go to the link on my show notes or to the link tree on any of my socials or if you connect with me on social media a great place to do that is on instagram and linkedin where i'm dr marianne trent for both of those you will absolutely be able to find information about how you can do that you might also find it useful to look and read the words of the Clinical Psychologist Collective. But I would love your thoughts on this episode. Please let me know if you are hurting or if you've hurt in the past
名额即将再次开放，我相信是在9月2日星期五上午8点。但你需要进入名单，只有在名单上的人才能加入。所以请点击我节目说明中的链接，或者我任何社交媒体上的Linktree。如果你在社交媒体上与我联系，Instagram和LinkedIn是很好的地方，我的名字都是Dr. Marianne Trent，你绝对可以找到关于如何操作的信息。你可能还会发现阅读《临床心理学家集体》的内容很有用。我很想听听你对这期节目的看法。如果你现在感到痛苦，或者过去曾感到痛苦，请告诉我，
and what advice was helpful for you. This is probably a good place to tell you about the free Facebook group, which, well, I'm going to let it out there. You know, I haven't created it yet, but I am paving the way for a free Facebook group. So I will make sure that that is up and running by the time this podcast episode lands. So yeah, come along, join the free Facebook group, which as yet doesn't have a name, but I'm fairly sure is going to be called the aspiring psychologist community with dr marianne trent so look out for that come and join and come and discuss your thoughts about today's episode won't you um thank you so much for being part of my world as ever come and subscribe to youtube come and like and follow the show on Apple or Spotify, wherever you are listening to. Yeah, do lots of good things such as tagging me in socials if you really enjoy an episode, telling other people about it. And I will look forward to catching up with you very soon for our next episode, which will be dropping into your ears from 6am on Monday. Thank you. And
什么建议对你有帮助。这可能是一个告诉大家免费Facebook群组的好地方。好吧，我要透露一下。我还没创建它，但我正在为建立一个免费的Facebook群组铺路。所以我会确保在播客发布时它已经运行起来。所以，来加入这个免费的Facebook群组吧，虽然目前还没有名字，但我很确定它会叫“有抱负的心理学家社区与Marianne Trent博士”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）。敬请期待，来加入并讨论你对今天节目的看法。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。一如既往，欢迎订阅YouTube，在Apple或Spotify上点赞并关注节目，无论你在哪里收听。如果你真的很喜欢某一集，请在社交媒体上标记我，告诉其他人。我期待着很快在下一期节目中与你见面，节目将于周一早上6点发布。谢谢。
if you found this helpful, I'm really glad. I will speak to you very soon. Take care. The Tricky Brain Kit. The Tricky Brain Kit. It's a kit on the course that helps you work with those that have depression or trauma. The Tricky Brain Kit. A tricky break it If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast.
如果你觉得这有帮助，我真的很高兴。我们很快再聊。保重。“棘手大脑工具包”（The Tricky Brain Kit）。这是课程中的一个工具包，帮助你与那些患有抑郁症或创伤的人一起工作。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将在获得资格的道路上前进。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》。
With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的途径。这让我充满了信心，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。